quatrième et avant dernier épisode de
notre série sur musée des arts premiers
quai branly à paris en attendant qu'il
ouvre ses portes le 23 juin prochain il
les ouvre au soir 3 depuis le mois de
février après le jardin voyage au centre
de la terre nous avons pu découvrir en
avant première quelques pièces de la
collection qui compte près de 300 mille
oeuvres et pour la première fois un
musée rendre à une partie de ses
réserves accessible au public le
reportage de christophe nardini et
romuald sera
bientôt le grand jour un mois à peine
avant l'ouverture officielle dernier
coup de collier dernière ligne droite
entre prouesses techniques et méthode
coué tout le monde se veut rassurant le
chantier sera livré en temps et en heure
après tout il ne reste que quelques
finitions mais comme chacun sait parfois
c'est ce qui prend le plus de temps
dans les entrailles du musée c'est un
tout autre tempo va et vient des
chariots apparemment anodin en fait
l'ensemble de la collection près de 300
mille oeuvres vont être entreposées ici
le coeur du musée recommencer à battre
c'est le sanctuaire c'est vraiment le
j'allais dire la raison d'être de
l'établissement c'est sa collection
c'est ce qui fait que autour ya le musée
et après qu'il y aura un certain nombre
d'espèces dans lesquelles ces
collections seront accessibles les zones
d'exposition temporaire le plateau de
référence avec les collections
permanentes les prêts qui vont être
faits pour d'autres institutions ainsi
de suite pour l'heure c'est le grand
déballage façon stockage massif avant
ouverture définitive un travail délicat
fastidieux et répétitif
comme une caissière de superviser il
faut archives et chaque objet
traçabilité oblige les oeuvres comme ses
sagas d'océanie ont quelque chose de
sacré à portée de main dans ses réserves
tout est contrôlé r quasi pur
température et hygrométrie constante sur
les étagères mousson néoprène et papier
de soie
de leur vie dans les réserves c'est pas
qu'un lieu de stockage c'est un lieu de
conservation donc c'est pour ça qu'on
doit leur apporter plus grand soin dans
le dans la conservation surtout en
utilisant des matériaux neutres autre
lieu autre ambiance une tour de verre un
peu comme une tour de babel 9000
instruments de musique un condensé de la
planète en fait une fois n'est pas
coutume une réserve qui se laisse voir
et qui se laisse entendre aussi
ceux ci l'ont aimée du son le met de la
musique en permanence comme lui-même
s'il était un instrument de musique du
xanax ans après en art science approche
on entend clairement le son de son
instrument produits sont qui est dans la
technique de jeu est présenté dans des
écrans qui sont disposés dans une
dizaine d'installations autour de la
réserve des instruments de musique dans
la section désastre humain nous est que
d'amérique
amérique du nord amérique du sud et on a
disposé la collection des flûtes sur ses
grilles
ces instruments pour la plupart ce sont
des instruments qui ont été ramenés au
cours de missions ethnographiques sur le
terrain donc ces désastres humains qui
était en état de jeu et qui jouait au
moment où les arts les arts accueilli
trois étages en dessous une des
collections les plus importantes au
monde celle des instruments d'afrique
beaucoup d'instruments à cordes pas
vraiment un hasard
c'était un petit peu pour casser des
certaines idées reçues parce qu'elle
allait venir il ya plein de gens qui
s'imaginent que l'afrique est le
continent du tambour série câblée
collection d'instruments et hambourg
sont très présents en afrique mais pas
dans toutes les régions faut savoir des
régions désertées pour lesquels n'y a
même pas de matériaux d'arbres pour
construire des tambours une réserve dans
un écrin de verre
l'occasion de rappeler aussi que la
musique comme le langage est le plus
vieux moyen de communiquer